you might think technology is the great
leveler and that ones and zeros don't
have racial bias
google's photos app apparently
automatically labeled a black couple as
gorillas
you'd be wrong
it's common knowledge that this
algorithm is racially biased
as technology races further and faster
ahead
is the world in danger of automating
racism
all kinds of structural inequality are
reflected in our ai systems and what can
be done to fix it
[Music]
yeah
suddenly i deep clean the car the
sanitization of stuff
you know it's even more important
for parmanjang keeping his car clean is
vital
working as an uber driver supported his
family and relatives back home in the
gambia
until he lost his job
par believes he's a victim of racial
bias built into uber's software
last april he got a message from uber
after my shift finished one night
came home
i was looking at my emails and i saw one
that says like
japan has been permanently deactivated i
thought it was just like a computer
mishap
following public concerns about customer
safety uber introduced a new system in
2020 to verify drivers identities
periodically drivers are asked to upload
selfies which are checked against photos
supplied when they first joined uber
despite providing numerous selfies par
says uber's algorithm failed to match
them to his profile
i didn't think much of the whole thing
because i thought if a human being
reviews it it'll be clear i'll be back
online the next morning
but parr says his account remained
deactivated
he later discovered he was far from the
only ethnic minority driver to have
experienced this in dignity i knew
from the stories that i come across
online
that some some of the black people have
got and the same experiences
with the uber algorithm uber employs at
least 70 000 drivers in the uk
52 of whom are from an ethnic minority
parr and a handful of other drivers are
taking uber to court for unfair
dismissal
they allege uber's algorithm
discriminated against them because of
the color of their skin
the company denies these claims
and says it uses a robust system of
human review to ensure decisions about
livelihoods are not made without
oversight
many technologies have a history of
embedded racism
in the 1970s kodak colour film was
unable to capture darker skin tones
accurately the company only fixed this
after chocolate makers complained its
photos weren't doing their products
justice
the racist history behind facial
recognition techno racism
[Music]
in recent times
microsoft facebook and google have all
had high profile problems with their
technology
just recently facebook's ai got it
terribly wrong when it put the label
primates on a video of black men
so what is going wrong
the simple answer is technologies are
trained using publicly available data
sets which do not include sufficient
data from ethnic minorities
the problems of the world include all
kinds of structural inequality
and those problems are reflected in the
data that we're using to train our ai
systems
it's commonly believed that technology
is neutral and free of bias
so one of the things that i write about
as a is an idea that i call
technochauvinism it's the idea that
technology is superior that
technological solutions are superior
as the world puts greater faith in
technology
embedded biases are affecting black
people in all aspects of their lives
during the covid pandemic pulse
oximeters have been essential in
measuring blood oxygen levels but then
researchers discovered that they gave
flawed readings for black patients
according to the researchers who
discovered this bias it was very
possible that darker skin patients were
turned away and sent home to
self-monitor because medical
practitioners thought that they were
doing well so this is one example of how
racial bias
can really be a matter of life or death
i don't actually think that the creators
intended to be racist i think that they
were probably a group of light-skinned
developers who tested it on themselves
and said oh it works for us it must work
for everybody
and if you want to buy a house
software might also discriminate on the
basis of your skin
color brooklyn native rachelle faroul
moved to philadelphia in 2015 hoping to
buy a home here
research in the u.s found that older
credit scoring algorithms used by some
mortgage lenders
favored particular financial behaviors
that are more common among white people
[Music]
black applicants for home loans were 80
percent more likely to be rejected than
white applicants from similar
backgrounds
[Music]
so what can be done to fix the problem
of racial bias with computers
data journalist meredith broussard and
her colleague thomas adams are working
on a solution
even if people don't think that race
data is being used
the computer may actually be using race
data because ais are making all these
decisions they're fighting fire with
fire by designing a unique set of
software tools to identify bias embedded
within technologies
once you set the standard then you can
refine the standard but until you do
that you don't really know what's going
on
i've partnered with o'neill risk
consulting in order to come up with what
we call a regulatory sandbox
which is a software system that
companies are going to be able to use to
test out their algorithms for bias in
order to confirm that
companies are not releasing biased
algorithms into the world
however observers worry that tech
companies cannot be trusted to police
themselves
for many companies
reducing racial bias will align with
their bottom line however
in the instances when reducing racial
bias does not align with the bottom line
it might be necessary to
regulate those companies
for many there's only one way to ensure
that systemic racism isn't built into
the digital future
much tighter regulation
we're at an interesting inflection point
right now
some of the changes that would need to
happen to combat racial bias include
government regulatory agencies to have
more resources to take action
but so far only the eu has started to
get serious about policing tech
companies big
and small a white paper on artificial
intelligence it's proposing a
groundbreaking principle the higher the
risk posed by an ai system to
fundamental rights the stricter the
oversight rules i do think that eu's
draft regulations are an important step
there still are some concerns because it
assumes that we have a shared
understanding of
what risk is and how to make those
calculations
without effective regulation and more
concerted self-policing
the old scourge of racism risks
blighting the new digital future
i'm tamara jokes for us policy
correspondent at the economist if you'd
like to learn more about vet tech bias
you can read my piece by clicking on the
link
and if you'd like to watch more of the
now and next series you can click on the
other link
thank you for watching and please do not
forget to subscribe